let me ask a ridiculous question
how hard is it to actually break a leg
this is something you think about i
remember
because i'm a big fan of the straight
foot lock
not again we're talking about to the
standing sanagi
maybe it's my uh russian roots with
samba or something like that maybe it's
the dean lister
uh achilles lock but i i love
maybe it's my body something like that i
just love the squeeze of it the control
and the power of a straight foot lock
and i remember
trying to there's a few people in
competition that
didn't want to attack absolutely and uh
i remember in particular there was one
one person it was a
again a finals match purple belt i
remember it was a straight foot lock is
perfect everything's just perfect and i
remember
going all in and there was a pop pop pop
and i couldn't do anything more it
wasn't breaking
it was it was just bending and bending
and bending and there's damage to it
of some kind but i wanted to like
you know i wanted to see first of all
it's very difficult psychologically
because it's like
can i be violent here that wasn't a
whole other
thing with adrenaline you can't really
think that fast but i also thought like
where
where else is there to go like is it the
shin going to break what is supposed to
break
so i wonder yeah in the case of the
achilles log it's going to be the
anterior tibialis tendon
and what's that uh that's the it runs
down there's two of them
uh it'll be the minor one that runs on
the outside of the front of the ankle
um it's not going to be the achilles
tendon a lot of people
promulgate this uh this absurdity the
achilles tendon
can rupture but not from pressure it's
rather standing or the bone it's going
to break
the bone won't break i have seen on one
occasion a shin bone break
from an achilles log but there was an
enormous
size and strength disparity and there
may have been other complicating factors
too
um but in the vast majority of cases the
achilles lock
doesn't really do tremendous damage it
can
do significant damage you'll definitely
feel it the next day but it's
of all the major locks it's the one
where it is most
likely a psychologically strong opponent
will be able to absorb
damage and go on to win a match and
answer to your first question
how difficult is it to break a leg um
not very difficult it will come down to
what is the skill level of my opponent's
resistance if your opponent is not
resisting and you have an inside heel
hook it is
absurdly easy to break a man's leg like
not a challenge at all
um you can be a 105 pound woman could
easily
snap um the the relevant knee ligaments
in a 240 pound man's leg if he doesn't
know how to defend himself that's
an easy thing very easy to accomplish
so the basic answer is yes it's very
easy
if your opponent does know how to defend
and they can position their foot
um play tricks of lever and fulcrum uh
it becomes significantly more difficult
becomes
still more difficult under match
conditions where they're actively
looking to
position their body and uh and work
their way out of the lock then it can
become very difficult indeed um
always bear in mind that there have been
some cases in our history as a team
where
people have literally just let their
knees
snap and continue fighting
always remember that submission is a
choice when it comes to the joint locks
and we've had some people who just made
the choice and i i'm willing to let my
knee break
so that i can can continue in this match
that's a tough decision to make and i
admire their bravery
um is there something about that just to
speak to that that you you
admire yes yeah it's mental toughness i
would i agree with it would i advocate
it no um but that doesn't mean i can't
admire
aspects of it
you